RICH HYNDMAN: --few minutes
later, hopefully with your
ticket in hand.
Says the optimistic Googler
in the group.
As usual, we've been discussing
Android development
topics prioritized from the
moderator, so please get your
questions into the moderator
each week as early as you can
so we get a chance
to look at them.
I'm Rich Hyndman, and I'm joined
here in London by--
CHRIS BANES: Chris Banes.
MATT GAUNT: Matt Gaunt.
Hi.
STEPHAN LINZNER: And
Stephan Linzner.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah, Matt,
Chris, Stephan, myself.
And on the Hangout, we've
already got Yossi.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Hi, guys.
RICH HYNDMAN: And Al.
AL SUTTON: Hey, guys.
RICH HYNDMAN: And Leonid.
Are you there?
Are you in the ooVoo
office as well?
You've got a remarkably similar
background to Yossi.
LEONID OLEVSKY: Yeah.
It's similar like Yossi.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: That
was my avatar.
RICH HYNDMAN: Lego Batman has
just joined us as well.
MATT GAUNT: That is
a good avatar.
RICH HYNDMAN: Wow, and a whole
room of people from the
Co-Creation Hub in Nigeria.
Hey there.
Good to see you guys.
STEPHAN LINZNER: Hi, guys.
RICH HYNDMAN: Thanks
for joining.
OK, does anybody in the Hangout
have a question not
related to Google I/O tickets?
AL SUTTON: I've got
a question.
If I've got multiple APKs, and I
have a service in one that I
want to make use of in the
others, is it better to export
the service in the manifest, or
should I just use AIDL and
embed the AIDL file
in the other APKs?
RICH HYNDMAN: This is
multiple, separate
applications on the same device,
as opposed to multiple
APKs in the developer console?
AL SUTTON: Yeah.
MATT GAUNT: Depends how much
control you want of the
service, really.
If you want to start calling
methods on the service, you
have to use AIDL.
If you just want to start
and stop it--
in fact, you can't
do that, can you?
YOSSI ELKRIEF: No, no.
MALE SPEAKER: You can't.
STEPHAN LINZNER: Are they
signed with the same
certificate, I guess?
AL SUTTON: No, they're going
to be signed with different
certificates is the thing.
MATT GAUNT: Yeah, I'd say
AIDL's your only bet.
RICH HYNDMAN: And you're always
going to guarantee that
the first app is on there when
the second app is running?
AL SUTTON: Yeah, the first app's
going to be on there
when the second ones
are running.
It's whether to use AIDL to use
the method call through,
or just try and have separate
intent services that handle
individual calls.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah, if you can
guarantee the first one's on
there, and then maybe there's
going to be multiple other
ones, I would go with
the AIDL myself.
AL SUTTON: Cool.
Thanks.
RICH HYNDMAN: Any others from
the Hangout floor before we
jump into the Moderator?
I'll take that as a no.
Welcome to the other six people
that just joined us.
I need to zoom in on the Chat
window again because we always
do this, and I can't
read it at all.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Yeah, nothing
in there for now.
RICH HYNDMAN: How do
you even see that
there's nothing in there?
There we go.
Jan, Clemens, Stephen, and J.
Miguel all joined us recently.
OK, should we grab one off
the Moderator, and
I'll make sure that's--
MATT GAUNT: Yeah, let's do it.
So Mike has asked about theming,
and specifically
about theming EdgeEffect.
So that's the glow you get when
you overscroll a List
View or any sort of scrolling
container.
And he's asked why can't you
style it by asking why can't
you change the color or
anything like that.
And the main reason for that
really is that EdgeEffect is
supposed to be consistent
across all apps.
It's for the user then to have
different colors and different
styles that you can
easily change.
It becomes a bit jarring.
So that's the real reason,
really, just to keep
consistency.
You can change it, but you'd
have to import the container
yourself and then
change out the
EdgeEffect and the drawables.
RICH HYNDMAN: Excellent.
I'm supposed to be taking
notes as well, aren't I?
STEPHAN LINZNER: We have another
question from Ram.
He's asking, when a service gets
restarted, will it reset
the timer under the App Settings
for its service?
I think it will, but
I cannot guarantee.
Maybe you just try it out.
Some of you guys know
about this behavior?
MATT GAUNT: I don't know.
It doesn't really make
a difference
anyway, because the timers--
STEPHAN LINZNER: Maybe he wants,
if the user goes in
there, so the user can see it.
But regarding the second part
of your question, what will
happen to static objects
referenced
inside the service class?
Any static object that lives
on the heap will be there
until your process terminates.
So of course, static objects
will be there, I also wrote in
the answer.
But you have to be very,
very careful.
If one of your static objects
keeps a reference on a service
or any other object that keeps
a reference on a service, you
will actually leak that service
when it's restarted.
So you have to be very careful
there because sometimes, it's
easy to create a memory
leak if you're
using a static object.
So you can do it, but
be very careful.
LEONID OLEVSKY: OK, can
I ask a question?
STEPHAN LINZNER: Of course.
LEONID OLEVSKY: I've played
with billing a service of
Version Three, and want to check
to get the SKU details
from Google Play, and the
list that I received was
blank with no items.
Does it work, or maybe I was
doing something wrong?
MATT GAUNT: Had you recently
updated the list on the
Developer Console?
LEONID OLEVSKY: I updated the
list, but the check that I was
doing was two or three
hovers after it.
And the list was empty.
MATT GAUNT: That's
interesting.
RICH HYNDMAN: The list
of prices, was that?
LEONID OLEVSKY: I did everything
that you have
written in the Developers
Android, and [INAUDIBLE].
RICH HYNDMAN: Two or three
hours is really
close to the wire.
It can take more than two or
three hours for these changes
to go through, the same
as when you publish an
application.
I've seen updates to
descriptions and graphics and
in-app billing take longer
than three hours before.
LEONID OLEVSKY: OK, but if
I call it, it works.
I don't have any problems
subsequently.
I will get the list of the
items, and I have published it
in Google Play.
OK, I will try another time.
MATT GAUNT: Yeah, because with
Version Three, it all gets
cached in the Market app,
Play app [INAUDIBLE], so
[INAUDIBLE]
is like a cache threshold.
If it hasn't been refreshed in
four hours, it will sort of
[INAUDIBLE] itself.
That's a guess.
RICH HYNDMAN: We hear a lot of
billing issues like this due
to not waiting long enough.
Unfortunately, we don't have an
exact, precise time for how
long it takes for the in-app
billing items to filter
through to your nearest cache
server for Play, but it
certainly can take
a few hours.
LEONID OLEVSKY: And can you
maybe make an example in the
code that you send, maybe for
checking the items for that
way, because the examples that
are going with the code is
only for buy items and
not for checking.
RICH HYNDMAN: OK.
I thought we did have sample
code for that in the--
we have a full sample
application that goes along
with it, as opposed to just the
sample code on the in-app
billing site, and the
application should have all
the sample code inside it.
MATT GAUNT: There's also demo
SKUs that you can check.
So you can change your Merchant
ID, and you'll get
all the demo ones.
So that's how you test if it
works, and then obviously, you
can then shift over to your
specific SKUs and test your
actual items.
So yeah, I'd just
wait, I guess.
LEONID OLEVSKY: OK, thanks.
RICH HYNDMAN: Have you found
the test application?
LEONID OLEVSKY: Sorry?
RICH HYNDMAN: Have you found
the sample in-app billing
application?
LEONID OLEVSKY: Yeah, I check
it, it's working fine, but
there is no sample for getting
a list from the Google Play.
You can only buy items or check
a subscription, not
getting the list.
RICH HYNDMAN: I thought it had
been updated to include
getting the list and finding
the prices, but I'll
definitely check it.
LEONID OLEVSKY: OK, thanks.
AL SUTTON: I've just done a
quick look into the source
code for the running time for
a service, and it's based on
the amount of time since that
process was started.
So if the service is restarted,
but the process
that service is in isn't
restarted, then the time under
the App Settings
won't be reset.
MATT GAUNT: OK, cool.
RICH HYNDMAN: OK.
What's up next?
Anybody got one?
I'll check the-- yeah?
STEPHAN LINZNER: Yeah, we had
a question regarding--
this might be an
important one--
regarding cursors.
Yeah, from Montano in Brazil.
He asked us, how can I don't
commit a cursor leak?
I'm using Content Provider and
AsyncQueryHandler to do a
simple query, but a cursor
leak happens.
Should I close the
cursor manually?
In general, you should always
close your cursors.
You should be really careful
about not leaking cursors.
Back on old APIs there,
you would call
Activity.startManagingCursor
and stopManagingCursor, and
then the activity or Android
would take over and manage the
cursor for you corresponding
to the life cycle.
But to be honest, you shouldn't
use any of these
classes anymore.
You should rely on
LoaderManager and
CursorLoader.
So take a look at them, and
they should help you out.
And also, take care of all
the life cycle stuff and
configuration changes and
all kinds of things.
So you should generally use
LoaderManager and CursorLoader
or other loaders.
MATT GAUNT: I've got a question
that Rich can answer.
Mr. J-R-E, MrJre, has
asked a question
about widget cell sizes.
So he said that on ICS
and Jelly Bean, the
cell size is 70--
you calculate it
a certain way--
and then on a tablet, you use
the same size, but it's only
three cells instead of four.
How would you combat that, the
different cell sizes on
different devices?
RICH HYNDMAN: The cell
size is the same on
all devices in dips.
Other than the fact we put
padding in Ice Cream
Sandwich and above.
Where was the question?
MATT GAUNT: It's the
second page.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Second page.
MATT GAUNT: MrJre.
RICH HYNDMAN: The formula for
JB, [INAUDIBLE], why is it
that 250dp width still
only spans three
cells instead of four?
I wasn't aware that it did.
I'm pretty sure--
on what device?
MrJre, if you're watching, what
device are you seeing a
four-cell, 250dp width widget
is only spanning three cells
and not four?
MATT GAUNT: Are you
sure it is--
goes to three cells, but
the cells are smaller?
Because of the padding, maybe
YOSSI ELKRIEF: No, maybe
it's a custom launcher?
MATT GAUNT: Yeah, maybe.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah, it should
definitely be spanning four
cells at 250dp of width.
So it's a bit of
a strange one.
If you have any more details
on it, then please put them
through about the device that
you're using, and I'll test it
over here as well, but I've not
seen that behavior before.
MATT GAUNT: So Jay in India
has asked about face
recognition.
He saw the OpenCV, which is
a popular native library.
It's been included in the
Android Source Tree for
awhile, and he's asking is
there any way he can get
access to that via the NDK?
Not that I'm aware of.
You can include an OpenCV
quite easily in your own
application.
There are some Java bindings
which I've released.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Yeah, it's better
to use it as an import
but not a--
MATT GAUNT: The only trouble
with using the Java binding is
that you're constantly doing
JNI calls, so it's going to
have a performance impact.
So you're better off doing all
the OpenCV calls in native,
and then only calling through
when you need to in JNI.
But I don't know an easy way
where you can easily use the
supplied OpenCV lib.
I don't really know.
RICH HYNDMAN: No.
CHRIS BANES: Me neither.
AL SUTTON: How about embedding
it in the application using
JNI to call through, so
recompile it and put it in an
application?
MATT GAUNT: Yeah, that's
what I said.
They supply a loaded sort of JNI
bindings, which are quite
nice, with OpenCV.
I've used it before.
RICH HYNDMAN: The other thing,
back on the widget sizing, of
course, is the Android Design
in Action last Friday, or
Thursday, or Monday, whenever
they published it, was on
designing widgets as well.
So if you are looking at
designing widgets for Android
applications, it's a great place
to go and check out.
On the Android Developers
YouTube channel, look for
Design in Action, and you'll see
all of their shows there.
And last week's was all about
designing widgets, and it did
have a section on the sizing
and the padding you have to
put on for the Gingerbread ones
and not for the Ice Cream
Sandwich and above.
Also, we have the AOSP ADT
template for widgets maybe
live now, or if not, it's
going live very soon.
So we got to do, from inside a
project, just right click for
a New Android Object, and choose
Widget, and then you
can choose what size, whether
it's configurable, whether
it's re-sizable, all
that sort of stuff.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: We've got a reply
on the widget sizes.
He has a Nexus 7, Moto Xoom,
Galaxy Nexus with default
launchers, all the same issue.
RICH HYNDMAN: Hm, interesting.
I just checked widgets
on here.
They are coming up with four
cells when they say they're
four cells.
AL SUTTON: Is the 250dp what's
being specified as the minimum
width, or is he just
specifying that
as a maximum width?
MATT GAUNT: Doesn't say.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: But it should,
on both cases, inflate four
cells and not three?
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah, I mean, I'm
running a Nexus 10 here,
and you've got a Nexus
7, is that right?
CHRIS BANES: Yeah.
RICH HYNDMAN: If you look at a
widget that says four cells,
is it a four-cell widget?
Some of the social network
buttons or the [INAUDIBLE]?
That's four cells there?
CHRIS BANES: Yes.
STEPHAN LINZNER:
It should be--
RICH HYNDMAN: Strange.
What's next?
We'll keep looking at that
at the same time.
CHRIS BANES: Four cells.
RICH HYNDMAN: Four cells.
MATT GAUNT: Marius has asked,
what do you recommend for use
in ListView, having rows with
multiple widgets, so you've
got two TextViews, a button,
et cetera, et cetera.
Do you recommend a CursorAdapter
or a space
Adapter with an ArrayList store
of a collection as its
data source?
RICH HYNDMAN: Has he got
a database behind it?
MATT GAUNT: Doesn't say.
So yeah, it totally depends on
what your data source is
previously.
If it's all in a database, it's
probably easier to use a
CursorAdapter with a
CursorLoader, and then you'll
get all the freeness, all the
goodness from having it
automatically update itself.
If you've got objects, then
creating a BaseAdapter is
probably the way to go.
It depends on your data source,
really, what model
objects you've got.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah, if you want
to do any custom caching,
just stick a BaseAdapter in and
put some code in there.
It depends what objects
you're doing.
If you're doing lots and lots
of bitmaps, it's a good idea
to at least hold the references
to those bitmaps
and as they go off the top and
you get them passed back in
again, load the new images
into the current bitmaps
instead of recycling the old
ones and loading new ones,
because you don't want your
heap to get fragmented.
STEPHAN LINZNER: Yeah, but you
also have to be careful.
Use a load cache or something.
Yeah, but I think that it
depends on your data source.
Do we have any other
questions?
RICH HYNDMAN: We kind of rocked
through them all in 16
minutes, or 18 minutes.
STEPHAN LINZNER: Any questions
in the Hangout?
RICH HYNDMAN: No.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: So,
how you doing?
No, just joking.
RICH HYNDMAN: Do the guys from
the Co-Creation Hub in Nigeria
have any questions for us?
MALE SPEAKER: No, no.
Not now.
RICH HYNDMAN: The quality is
much better today than the
previous time.
We can hear what you're
saying today.
MALE SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE].
RICH HYNDMAN: OK, we'll
carry on then.
I'll check the G+ thread.
I won't check the YouTube
comments because they're
always useless.
STEPHAN LINZNER: Yeah, there
are only comments on I/O.
RICH HYNDMAN: Apparently we're
being cruel doing a Hangout
whilst some people are suffering
over 500 server
errors and timeout.
Sorry about that, Rob, but
consistency is more
important to us.
Well, we just didn't want to
shift it by half an hour so
you could all just come
on and complain to us.
MATT GAUNT: That's
the real reason.
RICH HYNDMAN: That's the
real reason, yeah.
We could have done it half
an hour early, I guess.
MATT GAUNT: Kitesurfer has
asked, what are the do's and
don'ts when implementing
a custom
view group, like ViewPager?
It's a complex issue to
do this kind of stuff.
There's no do's and
don'ts to it.
Have a look at ViewPager.
It's very, very readable.
It's a very good example of how
to do a custom view groups
with an adapter base.
So I would learn from the
frameworks classes, rather
than trying to read books or
whatever, because they are
very readable.
Well, most are.
RICH HYNDMAN: Michell Bak has
chimed in saying that actually
if he uses 250 dps for min
height and min width, he's
getting three columns
on an SW600 device.
And he's actually put up 280
to get four columns.
If multiple people say
it, it's definitely
worth checking out.
STEPHAN LINZNER: Yeah, we have
to investigate on it.
MATT GAUNT: I was under the
impression that the cell sizes
change based on device
[INAUDIBLE].
STEPHAN LINZNER: You have
different cell sizes if you're
in Portrait and if you're
in Landscape.
RICH HYNDMAN: But the minimum
should always be the
same, the min width.
Should be number of cells
[INAUDIBLE] dps.
We shall investigate and
get back to you.
MATT GAUNT: Thorsten in Germany
has asked about the
Geocoder API, specifically
getFromLocation.
And he seems to be seeing
that you're getting some
intermittent issues with not
getting any results back or
500 issues.
Yeah.
There's not much
to say, really.
That server, I seem to remember
there being something
in the docs about you won't
always get replies.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah, we've had
a few cases of this before.
And the recommendation has often
been to use the Android
Geocoder API, and then if you
don't get a response, or you
get an unsatisfactory response,
use the web API as a
backup mechanism.
There's definitely some cases,
I can't remember what the
exact cases are, that you'll
just fall back on the web.
MATT GAUNT: It's quite an old
API, though, isn't it?
RICH HYNDMAN: It is.
Reverse lookup for addresses
and things.
MATT GAUNT: Yeah.
What was the case?
RICH HYNDMAN: It was something
to do with Wi-Fi or cell
networks, can't remember
which one.
MATT GAUNT: Sorry, we can't
really answer that.
RICH HYNDMAN: No, but there is
the web API, which is more
reliable and worth
falling back on.
MATT GAUNT: Google Maps.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yep.
Anything else?
Anything else from inside the
Hangout, as we're seeing what
new has appeared?
We've got 19 questions now.
We started the session with nine
questions, and 10 more
have appeared during
the session.
So you'll have to--
MATT GAUNT: It's all
the I/O people.
RICH HYNDMAN: Jacek's asked
me if there's any way of
customizing the included
Google apps--
Google Talk, Google
Play Store--
with customized look to feel
more like commercial Android
powered devices?
No, unfortunately not.
Of course, Google Talk, we have
a full API for Google
Talk, Yammer-based or
whatever it is.
MATT GAUNT: Jabber.
RICH HYNDMAN: Jabber?
So you can write your
own Google Talk
client if you want.
There are several out there, and
make it look nice themed.
Play Store doesn't have an API,
so you have to use the
Google branded Play Store.
But for all these kind of
questions where you asked who
to contact to talk about
support, it is if you go to
source.Android.c
om/compatibility, there's a
link at the bottom of the page
for joining the ecosystem, and
all of these things fall under
manufacturers that have passed
the Compatibility Test Suite
and become part of the
ecosystem, and then can talk
to their Partner Manager,
which is also nontrivial.
Did you find any more whilst
I was jabbering on?
MATT GAUNT: I've got one, and
Stephan will read it.
You've got anything, Stephan?
STEPHAN LINZNER: We have
a question right here.
I have two singleTask
activities, A and B. B is
started from A, and I want
from B to kill the app.
System.exit and
Process.killProcess will
result in closing B and
restarting A. Is there a way
to kill the whole app?
I think we've said this
multiple times before.
It's very, very bad practice to
kill your app because the
run time is actually managing
your app, and your app is only
killed in the case that there
are no resources and we have
to kill the process.
So you have to have a very
good reason to call the
functions you just
mentioned here.
So in general, you should find
a way for it and really not
kill your process or
exiting your app.
AL SUTTON: One of the ways of
doing it is if both A and B
register a broadcast listener,
and then you broadcast an
intent when you want to shut
down and just call Finish in
each activity.
That way, you're not killing
the actual process, you're
just killing off
the activities.
STEPHAN LINZNER: Just a
normal way you do it.
You would just call Finish on
both of the activities.
RICH HYNDMAN: All right, we have
a question from Constance
at the Co-Creation Hub.
CONSTANCE: Hello.
RICH HYNDMAN: Hi.
CONSTANCE: Constance.
I wanted to find out, what's
your take on using
table-oriented architecture for
data centric Android apps?
I just read an article about
it, and talking about this
[INAUDIBLE]
when [INAUDIBLE]
apps for [INAUDIBLE].
We have an app that [INAUDIBLE],
and we're
thinking of [INAUDIBLE],
considering if it would be
nice to switch and use
table-oriented architecture.
[INAUDIBLE] if it's possible
for mobile applications, or
what's your take on it?
RICH HYNDMAN: After what I said
before, we are having a
little trouble hearing.
MATT GAUNT: [INAUDIBLE].
STEPHAN LINZNER: Can you repeat
the question, or write
it as a comment?
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah, could you
just put the gist of the
message in a comment for us, and
we'll read it out, unless
anyone else in the Hangout
picked it up?
STEPHAN LINZNER: Can you scroll
down on the right?
RICH HYNDMAN: You were looking
into something, and you're
writing an application.
MATT GAUNT: Oh, there we go.
STEPHAN LINZNER: What's
your take on--
RICH HYNDMAN: Using
table-oriented architecture
for data centric Android apps?
MATT GAUNT: I don't even know
what table-oriented
architecture is.
STEPHAN LINZNER: You should
always provide the best user
experience per form factor.
So if you have a data centric
app and showing some content,
you should always make sure it
runs across all the devices,
from your smart phone to the
tablet, and use different
layouts for that, and think
about what is the best way I
could present my content
to the user.
So was this your
question, or--
CONSTANCE: Yeah.
When writing data centric apps,
how do you go about it,
personally?
MATT GAUNT: So table-centric
apps.
RICH HYNDMAN: How do you go
about writing data centric
apps, personally?
CONSTANCE: Your experiences
with that.
CHRIS BANES: It does depend
on what the use case is.
You'll have some where it's
fine to cache [INAUDIBLE].
You'll have other scenarios, if
you look at stock exchange,
the information is stale as soon
as you've got it almost.
So again, it's a case of you've
got to think of, what's
the best way of transferring
the data?
What time can you store it?
Does it ever need updating?
At what point does it become
useless, kind of, to the user?
It does depend on the use case,
and there's a lot of
variation in that,
in my opinion.
RICH HYNDMAN: Is the data in
your application static data,
or is it very dynamic?
CONSTANCE: Dynamic, so the data
will have to be stored on
the device [INAUDIBLE].
RICH HYNDMAN: So you'll be
frequently updating the data,
storing it on the device, and
showing it to the user?
CONSTANCE: Yes.
RICH HYNDMAN: And there's a
lot of data, I take it?
CONSTANCE: Sorry, I didn't
hear what you said.
Can you repeat the statement?
STEPHAN LINZNER: I think
Matt is right.
You have to come up with a
strategy on how you cache
data, when are you fetching
data, and all
these kind of things.
So what you can do in your
case, maybe if you have a
widget or something, you can
think about a strategy using
some exponential backup
logarithm and pull the data.
I don't know how often you have
to refresh your data, but
you can use a service in the
background and pull data from
time to time.
But in general, you have to look
at your requirements and
then from there, judge on your
strategy for caching when
you're loading data, when you're
doing pre-fetching, and
all this kind of thing.
It's important because it also
affects battery life, so you
also have to be careful there.
CONSTANCE: Thank
you very much.
RICH HYNDMAN: No problem.
And one minute before we finish
today, Mr. Terrence
Eden has joined the chat.
Hey there, Terrence.
Good to see you.
No microphone enabled today.
TERRENCE: Oh well, never mind.
RICH HYNDMAN: Oh no,
there you go.
Did you have a question you
wanted to sneak in in the last
minute of the conversation?
TERRENCE EDEN: I did.
I'm investigating using
Bluetooth, so I've got a new
DB port in my car so I can plug
a Bluetooth thing into
that, and I can communicate
with Android.
What I can't do is use AVRCP,
which allows me to update the
head end of my phone.
Now, I've seen some devices,
like some Samsungs and some
HDCs, have a Bluetooth stack
which do have that.
I just wondered if there's any
official way in stock Android
of doing anything useful
with Bluetooth.
RICH HYNDMAN: If you go to the
Bluetooth page in the API
docs, it shows you which
profiles are officially
supported in which versions
of Android.
We have a doc which
lists those.
So the audio profile, A2DP, is
supported, but you're only
guaranteed to have that lowest
quality audio supported.
MATT GAUNT: Yeah, I can't
remember what the codec's
called, but [INAUDIBLE].
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah, you can ask
the device if there are
better codecs on there, and
most of them will have.
But in terms of video,
there's no default
support in Android 4.
TERRENCE EDEN: I'm sorry, not
for video, but AVRCP allows
you to send messages, like the
track that you're playing.
I mean, we've been asking for
this since 2009 on the Google
bug thing, and haven't
heard any response.
My six-year-old BlackBerry can
do it, so I'm just wondering
if there's any way to get
that into Android.
STEPHAN LINZNER: Have you always
tried to use the Blues
library directly
in native code?
MATT GAUNT: I think it's been
compiled in there as a module.
STEPHAN LINZNER: It must be in
there because we are using.
Have you tried if you can do it
from native code, or is it
just not supported?
TERRENCE EDEN: If you look in
the Source Code for Android,
it says, using the Blues API
version 1.0 for now, and that
was a couple of years ago.
So the native Blues doesn't
have it, which is why I'm
wondering if there's any way to
go directly to Bluetooth.
If Google can't support a
five-year-old standard, what
else can we do?
AL SUTTON: Make a contribution
to the
Android Open Source project?
RICH HYNDMAN: Bingo.
TERRENCE EDEN: So it is in
CyanogenMod, so it has been
submitted to AOSP about
two years ago.
AL SUTTON: No, that's not
necessarily right.
CyanogenMod is a separate
fork-off of AOSP, so there may
not have been a contribution
given to the AOSP guys.
TERRENCE EDEN: I will
check and see if I
can push it on them.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah, we'll just
have to wait and see, I guess,
what the next version of Android
holds for Bluetooth,
but we clearly can't
pre-announce anything or talk
about future releases,
so I have no idea.
I hope that somebody
has picked up your
six-year-old issue.
From the day that Android
started, you are clearly
banging on for this one.
Thanks for joining us and asking
our final question of
the day, Terrence.
At least the profile
of the issue has
been raised even higher.
Thanks everyone else
for joining us
in the Hangout today.
We'll be back at
the same time--
will we be back at the
same time next week?
That's a good question.
The team is traveling next week,
and two o'clock is a
very awkward time in America.
We'll make an announcement
sometime soon about whether
we'll be at the same time next
week, and that's all for us.
Thanks very much for joining.
MATT GAUNT: Cheers, guys.
CHRIS BANES: Thanks, guys.
AL SUTTON: Bye.
LEONID OLEVSKY: Bye.